c'est d'avoir préfabriqués tous ces
éléments et qui représente la géométrie
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie roger
taillibert a été fier d'une de ses plus
grandes oeuvres
le stade olympique il parlait avec
fougue de ce mic l'ine qui le plus aux
demandes qui sert à rien c'est un dépôt
ce magasin c'est la halle de stockage de
montréal toutes les cochonneries on y
met dedans
architecte de renommée internationale
roger taillibert a réalisé près de 500
projets dont le parc des princes à paris
une immense structure de béton qui lui a
inspiré le stade olympique construit
pour les jeux de 1976 reste attaché très
engagé monsieur treiber avait encore de
très grande vision pour montréal la
peinture l'architecturé la musique qui
s'installe sans roger taillibert à
habiter au québec plusieurs mois par
année pendant près de 50 ans l'été
dernier une exposition de ses peintures
et de ses projets d'architecturé lui a
été consacrée à repentigny
le québec doit se souvenir de roger
taillibert vie ses amis feutray lui oui
ils ont fait preuve a été faussement
accusé de choses dont il était
absolument pas coupable
environ le stade coûte très cher mais
c'est pas lui je pense que roger
taillibert mériterait certainement de la
part de bien des québécois et
particulièrement au plus haut niveau en
fait des excuses pour ce qui s'est dit
deux choses
injuste le parc olympique de montréal
songe maintenant à lui rendre hommage
on a une réunion prochainement on va
réfléchir pour lui rendre hommage par
delà ce qu'on a fait à venir jusqu'à
maintenant à québec aussi
on a tenu à le saluer j'ai réagi avec
beaucoup de tristesse parce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer monsieur les
ibères cet été une très belle rencontre
j'ai découvert un homme d'une grandeur
particulière c'était un grand architecte
grand sportif roger taillibert nous
confiait quelques mois avant son décès
qu'il était fier d'avoir aidé la
jeunesse sportive de la base de la
société
l'une c'est la base de nos muscles c'est
la base de notre respiration ici louis
fait déprimer radio canada montréal